last night the top nine Democratic
presidential candidates and who leon
castro met in houston to debate all the
top issues and to promise the american
people a future with two cars in every
garage few teeth in every mouth and a
record player in every living room joe
biden feared the worst but no one came
out looking good we will examine the
highlights then the Trump administration
moves to outlaw vaping for all the wrong
reasons and Hillary Clinton tries out
performance art I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
last night's democratic debate felt like
performance art we got about three hours
of performance art I was on the crowder
livestream for it so you can check that
out too lots and lots of fun
Joe Biden probably couldn't have had a
worse night than he did we will get to
all of that in a second but first I have
got to thank our friends over at wise
foods it is very important to be
prepared during an emergency and looking
at last night's debate you can see a lot
of political emergencies and problems on
the horizon make sure that you are
prepared doesn't need to just be a
political emergency could be a natural
disaster could be something totally
unexpected could be an attack that will
leave you vulnerable wise company takes
an innovative approach in providing
dependable simple and affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use when
government resources are strained it can
be days if not weeks before you can get
to fresh food and water we've been
seeing this all around us for the past
just the past few weeks you cannot rely
on someone else you cannot rely on the
government you have to rely on yourself
and you can't know what tomorrow may
bring but you can have peace of mind
knowing that you'll be ready for it this
is actually what I love about wise foods
I'm actually kind of the opposite I
don't really prepare I should be more
prepared than I am generally but I don't
think about all those bad things that at
a certain point are going to happen I
just filled a certain level of stress
where I think gosh that gosh if that
doesn't happen maybe I won't be ready in
this and that and this and that just get
it today be prepared don't think about
it you can know that your most precious
commodity your family your family in
your life are taken care of and then put
it out of your mind and wait for it this
week my listeners can get any wise
emergency or outdoor food product at an
extra 25% off the lowest marked price at
wise food storage calm when entering
Knowles Canada wles at checkout or by
calling eight five five four five three
two nine four five plus shipping is free
wise has a 90 day no questions asked
return policy there is no risk in taking
the initiative to get yourself and your
family more prepared today that is wise
food storage dot-com
promo code Noll Skinner wles to get any
wise emergency or at door food product
and an extra 25 percent off and free
shipping joe biden's no good terrible
very bad night he looked old he looked
confused
he looked frail he couldn't sing finish
rather a single sentence and his teeth
literally fell out of his mouth he
caught him back right before they
totally flopped but his teeth actually
fell out of his mouth on the bright side
at least his eyeball didn't explode this
time there are silver linings to every
storm cloud so at least you got that his
eyeball didn't fill with blood like it
did on the last CNN Town Hall but
otherwise just about everything that
could have gone wrong did go wrong
including I know it sounds like I'm
joking but it's not a joke
his teeth literally falling out of his
mouth here it is at the time there was a
groundswell in this country to get
something done President Obama asked you
to leave the push for gun control you
have often pointed to your ability to
reach across the aisle to get things
done but four months after Sandy Hook a
measure to require expanded background
checks died on the Senate floor if you
couldn't get it done after Sandy Hook
why should voters give you another
chance because I got done before I'm the
only one up here ever beat the NRA only
one ever beginner and nationally Ohio a
little boy and then you can see as he's
trying to get that sentence that he's
saying I got it done before he uses his
tongue to push his dentures back into
place in the way that old men do in the
way the people who were dentures do not
just old men but other people who have
dentures unmistakable this is not about
the age this is actually not the age
issue we've known that Joe Biden has
fake teeth for a very long time at least
close observers know nobody on earth has
teeth that big and bright and shiny and
white and certainly not old men who have
been in politics for a long time there
is actually a website that went up at
least ten years ago called Joe Biden's
teeth calm and it's just and sort of ode
to his teeth you can go there I think
the website still up this is not about
the age what the issue is is that he
looks
and act his age Ronald Reagan was no
spring chicken he was the oldest
president American history but he didn't
seem like the oldest president he was
sprightly he was spry was full of energy
you know very famously when he went to
meet the Soviet dictator Mikhail
Gorbachev Gorbachev was a younger man
than Ronald Reagan and they were meeting
and Gorbachev's limo pulls up and Reagan
is waiting in the White House it's
wintertime and there was a debate going
on does Reagan wear the coat or does he
not wear the coat he wears the coat it's
wintertime that's appropriate if you
don't wear the coat you look younger and
more energetic doors open Reagan doesn't
have a coat on just his suit jacket and
he goes hopping down those little steps
and he embraces Gorbachev who's got the
big coat on and the big Soviet fur hat
and he he looked less energetic he
looked weaker he looked older and
Gorbachev was actually very upset about
this and at the end of their meeting he
said so next time are we gonna wear
coats are we not gonna wear coats
because he knew how it looked
Reagan understood the optics of age he
was asked by a Walter Mondale who was
running against him in the 84 race he
they they Mondale made some comment
about his age and Ronald Reagan answered
in the debate he said I will not make
age an issue in this campaign I will not
exploit for political purposes my
opponents youth and inexperience and
Mondale later commented that that was
the moment he knew he lost the election
because Reagan totally flipped that age
issue on its head Trump does the same
thing you know Donald Trump is out there
hanging out with Kanye West Donald Trump
for all his age is the hippest guy in
the country Chris Rock said this about
Joan Rivers when Joan Rivers died she
was 80 years old she was making jokes
about Beyonce she was so hip there are
much younger comedians who are out there
making jokes about Bill Clinton you know
there who aren't hip at all even though
they're 30 or 40 years old Trump is hip
if you look at his Twitter picture that
Twitter picture that you see that he
hasn't changed in a long time that's
from 2005 that was from when he was
doing The Apprentice and he hasn't
changed it but you probably haven't
noticed because the guy doesn't really
age I think it's all that fast food
all that diet coke has sort of preserved
him in this eternal form same thing with
his hairy obviously colors his hair
Ronald Reagan colored his hair too they
just seem young and Joe Biden doesn't
seem young he seems old Biden also talks
like someone who isn't with it so it's
not even just the way he acts and the
teeth falling out and and the this the
cadence of his voice it's out also what
he's saying
so if Trump is out hanging out with
Kanye Trump is hosting Saturday Night
Live Joe Biden is talking about how we
need a record player a gramophone in
every home that's not an exaggeration
here is Joe Biden's answer to a question
about the legacy of slavery we make sure
that every single child does in fact
have three four and five-year-olds go to
school school not daycare school we
bring social workers into homes and
parents to help them deal with how to
raise their children it's not that
they'll want to help they don't want
they don't know quite what to do play
the radio make sure the television the
excuse me make sure you have the record
player on at night the phone make sure
the kids hear words a kid coming from a
very poor school I have a very poor
background will hear four million words
fewer spoken by the time they get there
there are two incredible aspects of this
clip one he corrects himself he says
make sure the televisions on at night
which these days is actually a little
bit outdated because people don't have
regular TV they pretty much just watch
everything digitally or on online or
streaming services but you could have
gotten away with that he corrected
himself though he he said make sure the
television is no I mean the record
player put the record player I know I
didn't mean that I mean have have
ancient Greek orders singing comedies in
your I don't know how much older you can
get the man but he is regressing to this
older technology and that's not even the
worst part of his answer that's the
first amazing aspect of the second
amazing aspect of this answer is he's
basically insulting the core voter group
that he needs to get through this
primary and then also to get through the
general election
what he said in his answer is we need
the government to come in to the homes
of black parents because black parents
don't know how to raise their kids
that's what he's saying he's saying oh
the problem is you know we need we need
to take those kids out of the home at
age three make sure they go into a state
institution we need social workers do in
the home because the parents they don't
know what they're doing they don't know
how to raise their own kids and it's not
even just a general comment about
Americans it's not a class comment it's
not a socio-economic comment it's
specifically a race comment because he's
answering a question about the legacy of
slavery Joe Biden his main argument here
is electability that's really the only
reason he's at the center podium it's
the only reason he's leading in the
polls part of the reason he's electable
is one he seems a little more moderate
than some of the other candidates but
the other one is the other candidates
are polling at like 0% among black
voters and Democrats need black voters
in order to win Joe Biden is going out
there and specifically insulting black
voters and then just when I was
wondering I was watching the debate I
thought why is only on Castro in this
stage why is this nothing empty suit
joke of a candidate on this stage just
when I thought that he showed me why he
was on that stage he made the most
vicious attack against Joe Biden of the
entire night we'll get to that in a
second but first I have got to thank our
friends over at ring because safety is
very very important especially if some
of these clowns take over the country
safety is going to be even more
important rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer now you probably
already know that there's smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere they
protected me ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or a surprise visitor you get an alert
you'd be able to see hear and speak to
them all from your phone this has
happened my senior producer Jonathan hay
woke up in the middle of the night and
fortunately because of ring he was able
to scare off a couple of wackos trying
to break in other friends that I had
given my ring to as a housewarming gift
they were hearing bump in the night they
were afraid there was some drug addict
or some robber trying to break
because of their ring device because the
camera because of the cloud features on
there
they were able to see the big scary
intruder was a possum and now they have
a possum and they kind of like the
possum but it gives you peace of mind
even you've got a package delivery guy
maybe you've got a robber maybe you've
got your mother-in-law trying to break
in it's very unclear which of those
would be worse your ring will let you
see here and speak to those people
whether you're at the office whether
you're in your house whether you're on a
beach as a listener you have a special
offer and a ring starter kit available
right now with video doorbell motion
activated floodlight camera the starter
kit has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
own home go to ring.com slash knowles
KN o WL es go there right now
ring.com slash knowles so I'm wondering
what who Leon Castro is still doing on
that stage he should have gotten off
weeks and weeks ago I was actually on
Leland Vitter's show on Fox News when
the news broke that who Leon Castro was
going to run for president and Leland
turned to me said Michael I want to get
your reaction just right off the top
here - who Leon Castro making this big
announcement I said I've got a big
announcement Leland I had a ham and
cheese omelet for breakfast both of
those announcements are of equal
relevance to the 2020 presidential
contest who Leon Castro is going nowhere
but before he goes nowhere
he can just Shiv Joe Biden right in the
side he comes out there and he just
flatly accused joe biden of being
completely senile here he is Barack
Obama's vision was not to leave 10
million people uncovered he wanted every
single person in this country covered my
plan would do that your plan would you
do not have to buy in they do not have
to buy you just said that you just said
that two minutes ago you just said two
minutes ago that they would have to buy
in you said they would have to buy to
buy in if so Paulo fire are you
forgetting what you said if Maddox gonna
be in for
you snapped just two minutes ago I mean
I can't believe that you said two
minutes ago
that they had to buy in and now you're
saying they don't have to buy you're
forgetting that look grandmother who has
no money she will curses you're
automatically enrolling this was a
pretty ugly exchange and pretty brutal
attack from Castro I think the attack
actually made Castro look even worse
than he already did I mean it's so nasty
it's so disrespectful also it wasn't
true Joe Biden I'm happy to criticize
Joe Biden but Joe Biden had said if you
don't have enough money you are
automatically enrolled so even the
charge that Castro is making simply
wasn't true nevertheless it looked
really bad for both these guys just fine
for me because Joe Biden is currently
the front-runner and what's wild is when
Castro decides he's gonna turn the
attack from you're lying to you're an
old man who's seen aisle said are you
forgetting what you said two minutes ago
Biden is so visibly disgusted he turns
away from Castro but then because Bernie
is to his right he just starts talking
to Bernie and it looks like those two
old Muppets like ma you know the ones up
in the up in the balcony the RonRon
around the big white hair and the
mustache ass and everything so it really
truly was a bad look for everybody all
around the look obviously is not gonna
help Castro Castro is going nowhere but
Joe's troubles keep multiplying because
Biden's actual answers were terrible too
it's not just the way other people made
him look or his dentures slide around it
was his own answers they were rambling
he was unable to finish a sentence he
did sometimes contradict himself
worst of all cuz he could get past all
of that that's built into Joe Biden
worst of all the answers were radical
and he can't survive that he keeps going
back and forth he keeps vacillating you
see the moderate elder statesman or is
he the leftist radical he keeps it every
day he goes back and forth one day he's
just gonna preserve in a more moderate
way the legacy of Obama he's been in set
the Senate for 50 years the next day he
wants to repeal the Hyde Amendment
he's sorry he ever did that and he's
sorry that he passed criminal justice
reform the 1994 crime bill he can't
decide which he's going to be the reason
he can't decide it's not even that he's
desperate and he is just trying to be
cynical it's that he doesn't have any
actual beliefs he is the definition of
an empty suit he always has been
he had to drop out of the race in 1988
because he was stealing other people's
words he doesn't even have his own words
to say he is nothing he will be anything
and everything to everybody he just
wants to smile and get elected and be
applauded he is the definition the proto
- the archetype rather of a glad-handing
empty politician so that's why you can't
decide how to handle these questions he
actually can't even decide how to handle
his main legislative achievement which
was the 1994 crime bill actually a very
good crime bill so the 1994 crime bill
is a bill that led to what some people
would call mass incarceration I would
call it getting tough on crime and
jailing criminals which is a good thing
and the crime rates dropped dramatically
they went way way down now he was asked
a question about criminal justice reform
he goes full radical he says we should
barely put anybody in jail nobody should
be in jail for a non-violent crime as
when we were in the White House we
released 36,000 people from the federal
prison system nobody should be in jail
for non-violent crime you are the
architect of mass incarceration you
personally you're the guy and it was a
good idea and it helped and it worked
and you could run on that record now
you're saying nobody but violent
criminals should be in jail period this
is probably the single stupidest answer
Joe Biden could possibly give and what
he thinks he's doing what he thinks he's
doing is pandering to the black voters
that he needs that are sort of his
superpower against Bernie and Elizabeth
Warren actually though it's the opposite
it's not pandering to black voters it's
a betrayal of black voters or it will be
perceived that way at least because what
he
saying would disproportionately help
wealthy white people and it would
disproportionately hurt poorer black
people how so
because even beyond the racial element
there is a class element here just even
just look at the money you know so much
of the debate last night was about the
wealth gap between white and black so
much of the discussion of criminal
justice was about this wealth gap how
white people on average are wealthier
and black people on average are poorer
and therefore there's no justice in
America there are two different
America's consider the effect of Joe
Biden's answer if nonviolent criminals
are not in jail that means that
investment bankers who commit financial
crimes disproportionately very wealthy
disproportionately white get off
scot-free
you're a fraud stirrer you're running a
Ponzi scheme you're doing any that you
get off scot-free
but a guy who robs a liquor store goes
to prison the wealthy white guy isn't
robbing the liquor store this is just a
terrible answer and by the way you know
I have family members who were victims
of nonviolent crimes fraud that sort of
thing has devastating effects on
families can lead to death I mean it can
really lead to just awful I mean is the
fraud is the worst crime fraud is the
worst crime and is the worst sin it is
what Dante puts in the very center of
Hell with Satan in his three-headed
mouth there is three mouths Ted I guess
chomping on the fraudsters there is
nothing worse than fraud and what Joe
Biden is saying is yeah if you commit
front that's fine you go free you know
you shouldn't go to jail for that just
absurd I mean really a disgusting answer
and practically speaking unfortunate and
encounter productive for what Biden's
trying to do absurd and radical what
about immigration crimes they don't go
to jail what about what is basically
saying nonviolent drug crimes don't go
to jail that's just one sort of
non-violent crime even the possession of
illegal weapons
let's say you've got a whole slew of
illegal weapons in your house but it's
not our violent crime right you don't go
to jail so that's the absurd and the
radical answer if voters want absurd and
radical they are going to vote for
Bernie Sanders or who Leon Castro or
somebody like that they're not going to
vote for Joe Biden this is a losing
battle for him and if Biden doesn't
change course he's gonna lose this
bigger fight as well but Biden was not
the wrongest candidate of the night
there are wrong gurke ANDed 'it's on
that stage the longest candidate of the
night award actually goes to a candidate
that some conservatives like or at least
pretend to like which is Andrew yang he
tries to revive his struggling campaign
by literally buying votes politicians
buying votes totally unprecedented never
happened before right we'll get to why
that's the wrongest answer we'll get to
the most frivolous answer and we'll get
to one little glimmer of sort of not
really but almost kind of hope in the
Democratic Party first let me thank my
friends over at Boland branch guys I
have really high standards okay I'm
easily pleased I am satisfied by the
very best of everything this is
especially true of my sheets trouble is
I don't want to frivolously spend money
okay especially on my daily wire salary
I mean Shapiro pays me like twice a year
so I need to make sure I'm wise about my
money
bolon branch is the answer everything
Boland branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton which means they start out super
soft and they get even softer over time
I've had the privilege occasionally on
the road of staying in really nice
luxury hotels first thing I noticed is
the bedding it just feels different than
the sandpaper that I'm usually sleeping
on or that I was sleeping on when I was
a bachelor certainly so I thought how do
I get these really high quality sheets
when I go to get married I'm creating my
registry and I said I want really good
high quality sheets turns out in stores
luxury sheets can cost I kid you not a
thousand dollars you could pay a
thousand dollars for those really high
quality sheets that you get at the Ritz
or the Four Seasons
but with Boleyn branch those same
quality sheets and they are exactly the
same quality I'm telling you or only a
couple hundred bucks how do they do it
they cut out the middleman they go right
to you they avoid there's a
markups everyone who tries Boleyn branch
sheets loves them that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews you spend
a lot of time on your sheets if you're
me you spend I don't know two-thirds to
four-fifths of the day on your sheets
make sure they're good life is too short
okay life is too short for bad wine it's
too short for bad cigars and it's
certainly too short for bad sheets get
some luxury especially at a great price
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund but you will not want
to send them back there is no risk and
no reason not to give them a try to get
started right now my listeners get $50
off your first set of sheets at Boleyn
branch calm promo code Michael mi CH AE
L Boleyn branch calm today you will get
$50 off your first set of sheets Bo ll
and branch calm promo code
Michael Boleyn branch calm promo code
Michael so Andrew Yang's big idea is
he's gonna buy votes and he says this is
unprecedented this is not only
precedented this is the oldest idea in
politics the very first politician
walking out of the cave realised that
there were two easy ways to win
political support threaten somebody with
the club and buy them with goods and
services and money and that's what this
guy is promising and it's an old idea
it's a cynical idea and it's a wicked
idea to pay people to go away and to get
the entire middle class hooked on
welfare it's bad it's wicked it's it's
like the logical end of neoliberalism of
this idea that all that matters is
getting GDP to go higher and higher and
higher and and really not pay attention
to any other aspect of society but it is
not a serious solution and it would have
disastrous consequences and also the way
you know it's a really bad idea is it
relies on silly euphemisms I mean that's
what political correctness is is just
relying on deceptive euphemisms he says
you're getting a freedom dividend a
freedom dividend freedom dividend which
is the product of coercing people taking
their money away and then giving it to
you so that you get hooked up hooked on
the government teat doesn't sound like a
freedom dividend to me it's a very bad
idea it's a way to get people hooked on
government hooked on depend
see and to pay them to shut up and stay
home and shoot up opioids and if they
killed themselves too bad that's what
it's not a real solution to the the
problems plaguing our country it's just
a way to make it look like it's going
away
so yang was the wrong ggest candidate
the most frivolous candidate of the
night was gonna go to you only on Castro
but then he got that knock in at Biden's
so okay he actually did something he had
some use the most frivolous award goes
to drumroll please
Cory Booker Cory Booker we don't need to
really get into the substance of his
answers because it's Cory Booker you
know it's not not gonna be all that
relevant pretty soon but he repeated one
canard that he just can't drop and that
takes away a lot of his credibility he
called Trump a racist they all call
Trump racist but then he got specific
and where you get specific is where you
can be proven wrong
he said that Trump is not able to
condemn white supremacy here he is it's
not just an issue that we hear a
president that can't-can't my supremacy
you can't condemn white supremacy right
he can't do it Trump could never condemn
white supremacy or racism or bigotry
except oh hold on wait a second he's
done it repeatedly for years to refresh
your memory
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals and
thugs including the KKK neo-nazis white
supremacist and other hate groups that
are repugnant to everything we hold dear
as Americans and I'm not talking about
the neo-nazis and the white nationalists
because they should be condemned
totally we are a nation founded on the
truth that all of us are created equal
we are equal in the eyes of our Creator
we are equal under the law and we are
equal under our Constitution those who
spread violence in the name of bigotry
strike at the very core of America how
many times do I have to reject I've
rejected David Duke rejected David Duke
I've rejected the
KKK the Ku Klux Klan from the time I'm
five years old I rejected them I put it
on Twitter last week now I haven't been
asked this question so many times I have
rejected it so many times
I'm not buying it mr. president
okay Cory Booker says you can't condemn
white supremacy so I know I mean what
you only condemned it there like what
like 200 times or something so anyway
that's a Cory Booker this hurts him to
say this kind of stuff he's he just
seems shrill which is his vocal problem
and the shrillness goes to the content
of what he's saying to nobody not even
the Democratic voters believe that they
don't believe that he can't condemn
white support that Trump can't condemn
white supremacy he does they know he has
now what Booker could say is and Trump
he's using whistle dog whistles he is
using rhetoric that is actually giving
cover to white supremacists even though
he's explicitly condemning them I mean
he could come up with some kind of
twisted logic to still call Trump a
racist well acknowledging reality but if
Booker's not going to acknowledge
reality reality ain't going to
acknowledge him we will get to what I
think is the most important part of the
debate the difference between the
serious candidate and the frivolous
candidates we'll get to that in a second
and we'll get to vaping and Hillary
Clinton performance art but first I've
got to say goodbye to Facebook and
YouTube go over to daily wire calm ten
bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership you give me you get
the Andrew Klavan show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you get the Matt Walsh show
you had to ask questions in the mailbag
you get another Kingdom which we just
recorded episode two of yesterday and it
sounds super cool and the story is just
absolutely terrific most importantly you
get the leftist here's tumblr there are
nine more Democratic presidential
primary debates that's I did not
misspeak but it's not erroneous nine
more of these things you will drown if
you don't get the tumblr get the tumblr
right now protect yourself protect your
family go to daily wire.com we'll be
right back
the main thing that became clear in this
debate is that we are now in a 3-way
race you know anything could happen but
what it's looking like now is we have a
three-way race that 3-way we race is
between Biden Bernie and Elizabeth
Warren the difference between the
serious and the unserious candidates
became pretty clear in this debate and
you could tell this most clearly by
their answers on guns
so other than maybe Bernie every single
one of these candidates wants to take
away all of your guns but listen to how
they go about it there's the desperate
way the bado way which is to say hell
yeah
yeah hey man and to promise to steal the
most popular guns in America hell yes
we're gonna take your ar-15 your ak-47
yeah we're gonna take away the most
popular gun in America and we're gonna
take away your Second Amendment rights
the second most important one they put
it as number two it's in the
Constitution yeah we're gonna do that
that's not a serious candidate that's
not a serious general election candidate
it also reveals to you something that I
have long said which is when Democrats
tell you that they're not going to take
away your guns don't believe them they
will take away your guns here's baito of
work I think like three weeks ago not
very long ago
bethe o Rourke on a CNN Town Hall is
asked are you gonna take away our guns
he says no I strongly support the Second
Amendment I don't want to take yours or
anyone elses guns hell yes we're gonna
take your ar-15 your ak-47 three weeks
that's what it what a difference that
little bit of time makes so of course
and I think all of them are disingenuous
on guns I think they all want to take
away your guns maybe Bernie slightly
accepted but that's it if you're gonna
take people's guns as is a really dumb
way to go about it you're clearly not
thinking that you are going to be a top
tier of presidential candidate the
smarter way to grab guns is the
Elizabeth Warren way which is to put the
issue into real context we've actually
said in recent days that there are
things you can get done with Republicans
in the Senate what can you get done on
gun control so let's start by framing
the problem the right way we have a gun
violence problem in this country the
mass shootings are terrible but they got
all the headlines children die every day
on streets in neighborhoods on
playgrounds people die from violence
from suicide and domestic abuse we have
a gun violence problem in this country
and we agree on many steps we can take
to fix it my view on this is we're gonna
nut it's not gonna be one and done on
this we're gonna do it and we're gonna
have to do it again and we're gonna have
to come back to some more until we've
taught the number of gun deaths in this
country significantly this is how you
know she's running to win this is how
you know that she is getting serious
she's not just demagoguing this
ridiculous issue about the ar-15
the ar-15 is involved in very very very
few gun deaths or homicides each year
very few more people are killed by hands
and knives some hammers and baseball
bats then all rifles combined including
the ar-15 in the AR ak-47 you are 22 or
23 times more likely to be killed with a
handgun a pistol than you are with any
kind of rifle including the ar-15 the
ar-15 is a total red herring it's a it's
a complete complete mislead on the issue
the real issue is suicides and handgun
homicides and gang violence and Liz
Warren gives what's actually a pretty
good answer on the gun question
especially if you're of the opinion that
we can regulate guns or we should
regulate guns more my opinion but that
certainly is the opinion of the
Democratic Party and even many
independent-minded Americans this was a
great answer on guns really sharp really
well done you know she's in it I mean
she thinks she's gonna get it and the
polls seem to be reflecting that and I
think overall she helped herself last
night she helped herself a lot but she
helped herself show she's the stable one
she's not too old she's not too crazy
I think she's gonna play this slow and
steady wins the race kind of strategy
and it appears so far to be working
honorable mention for the night before
we get to vaping and before we get to
Hillary Clinton performance art is the
nearest to moderation
that's the honorable mention to Amy
Klobuchar for Minnesota she was asked
about health care she said maybe just
maybe we shouldn't take away health care
from 149 million Americans and believe
it or not this was the closest thing to
moderation all night I think you know
that I don't agree with some of these
proposals up here George so I'm talking
about if I could if I could respond to
some of the proposals but from my
friends but when it comes to our health
care and what comes to our premiums I go
with the doctor's Creed which is do no
harm and while Bernie wrote the bill I
read the bill and
page 8 on page 8 of the bill it says
that we will no longer have private
insurance as we know it and that means
that 149 million Americans will no
longer be able to have their current
insurance that's in four years I don't
think that's a bold idea I think it's a
bad idea
well said that's she's clearly learned
to the lessons of Obamacare pretty
decent answer it's why she's going
nowhere
enough of the loonatics enough of them
there will be nine more of these debates
which is just absolutely mind-boggling
that this will go on another nine times
so let's not spend any more time on this
one we have to get to the much more
important issue which is vaping yes
vaping the Trump administration is
reportedly moving to ban flavored
e-cigarettes or vapes listen you've seen
the vapes you know a little electronic
pack and people who suck in out of them
and then they breathe that water vapor
kind of smoke I'm not a fan of
electronic cigarettes I'm not a
proponent of them at all if you are
going to ban them ban them because they
are super lame don't ban them for these
kind of silly reasons that they're
coming up with ban them because real
tobacco is much more delicious than that
fake weird baby stuff don't ban them
because of some dubious health claims
there have been a few deaths and there
have been a few illnesses related to
vaping broadly but they're not related
to e-cigarettes the deaths have not been
specifically to ID cigarettes they have
been however tied to the weed pens the
vape that has THC in it and the
marijuana substance which is brings up a
very strange aspect of our culture I've
clearly been vaping a little too much
myself the strange aspect is the culture
is increasingly anti tobacco but it's
also increasingly Pro we'd like very
much so even though marijuana is in many
ways much worse for you than tobacco you
want
you won't hear I know all the potheads
are gonna like tweet at me all I really
know but it is it is marijuana smoke
deposits four times as much tar into
your lungs as tobacco smoke does now you
might say okay but people smoke a lot
more cigarettes than they do joints
maybe you haven't met my friends in the
music industry people can really smoke a
lot of pot I've smoked pot a number of
times in my life it's not like I'm
unfamiliar with the substance it's just
really weird to me I don't really care
for pot I much prefer alcohol and
tobacco
it's very strange to me though that at
the same time we are vilifying tobacco
is the greatest evil on earth we are
making weed into this great cure-all you
know it's kind of the caricature of Joe
Rogan is like yeah man we just solves
every problem makes everything way
better and I just don't believe that at
all I have a pothead friend who was at a
concert at Madison Square Garden and I
think it was like fish or something it
was some one of these like pothead bands
and he pulls out a joint and he's
smoking it and the security guards come
up in there like you have to put that
out right now you could get arrested you
have to put that out but he looked
around him and people were all around
him we're passing joints so he said well
no they're all they're all smoking
joints too and this was actually back
before it was decriminalized this was
probably number of years ago at this
point and they said it no no it's not
it's not the pot it's it's that you're
smoking a cigarette and I apparently his
marijuana was of such poor quality that
they thought it was tobacco it didn't
have the classic smell so he said no I'm
I mean really this is weed and they said
nobody you've got to put that cigarette
out it's one thing if it's pot you're
allowed to smoke that but not marijuana
so what is this vape ban really about
it's not about health I mean all of the
headlines are about e-cigarettes really
what it should be about is hey maybe
let's not look at all that let's watch
out on these weed pens one of the
reports is that it has to do
specifically with the vitamin E acetate
that's in the e that in the weed pens or
in cheaper versions of the weed pens or
in Chinese imports of the weed pens or
some other chemicals involved there too
what this vape pen is about is not
health it's about the government
enforcing a new secular morality
actually regardless of your views on pot
or tobacco or whatever I don't really
care your views about any of those
things and the government doesn't care
your views about it either what they
want to do is force their secular
morality on you so in that new secular
morality tobacco and tobacco related
products are simply evil and they must
go even if their vape pens even if
they're significantly better for you
than smoking cigarettes I don't think
this is a Trump administration thing I
think it's a government thing I think
this would have happened if Hillary won
in 2016 and would have happened under
Obama this has been a long time coming
they've been trying to ban the vapes
since they first hit the scene you know
I remember in bars in New York right
when the vapes came out almost in the
vape is just water vapor that comes out
of your mouth
almost immediately signs know vaping
said why no vaping it's not even the
arguments for secondhand smoke which are
dubious arguments to begin with but even
that you know you say ok I don't want to
breathe in that smoke but the vape is
just water vapor why can't I breathe
that out there's nothing that you're
breathing in other than the water vapor
because it's not about anyone's health
it's about controlling what you do same
thing on the airplane so why can't you
vape on an airplane it's just water
vapor because the government needs to be
able to tell you exactly what to do it's
a it's a lot like the environment you
know there are a lot of these
environmental regulations that in no way
help the environment they're not about
the environment they're about regulation
the health regulations aren't about
health they're about regulation so we
have a ban on plastic one use shopping
bags in Los Angeles you can't use the
plastic shopping bags instead you have
to use paper shopping bags the paper
shopping bags are much worse for the
environment takes a lot more energy it
harms the natural environment much more
to make those shopping bags and you have
to reuse the shop the paper shopping
bags three times in order to bring down
the environmental impact to the level of
the plastic single-use shopping bag
which people already used multiple times
anyway because they use them as trash
bags ever since they ban those the
purchase of the much heavier much more
environmentally damaging thick plastic
bags has shot through the roof but it's
not about the environment
those cotton bags that they make you buy
at the store if you buy an organic
cotton shopping bag you would need to
use that thing
20,000 times before you bring this
environmental impact down to the level
of a single-use plastic bag
they don't care when they find this out
when the studies come out they don't say
okay we're gonna pull back that
environmental regulation it's not about
the environment it's about regulating
you controlling your life and that is
why I don't like vape pens I don't like
pot I fight these kind of restrictions
as hard as I can because they're not try
it be one thing if you want to keep
marijuana criminalized I think that's
probably a good idea mostly cuz it'll
irritate the potheads and I get a kick
out of that but when it comes to
something like vaping a new technology
if you are just trying to regulate it
just to regulate it I resist that that
kind of rule as hard as I can
government should not be able to tell me
what to do as a simple arbitrary random
exercise in their own massive power
speaking of power-hungry government
officials Hillary Clinton the sort of
desiccated cadaver of Hillary Clinton
wandering around the woods of Chappaqua
has made it all the way to Italy has
made it to the Venetian Teatro Italia to
participate in performance art she is
now in an exhibit where she is sitting
at a perfect replica of the resolute
desk in the Oval Office
reading through her emails or you know
pages that are made to look like her
email 60,000 of them she sat there for
hours truly her not not an impersonator
reading an exhibit titled Hillary the
Hillary Clinton emails created by the
artist kenneth goldsmith this is art
somehow it's performance art the reason
i find this interesting is one it's
pathetic it's pathetic that this woman
who wanted to be president is so ruined
by this that she now needs to sit and
play pretend at a replica of the
resolute desk because I guess they take
her straitjacket off for a few hours a
day so she can participate in this
performance art but also because she's
not the first very prominent government
official to dabble in art after she
leaves office
George W Bush after he left the
presidency became an artist i believe at
the urging of the historian john Gaddis
who was actually professor of mine he
handed Bush an essay about how Winston
Churchill became a painter after he left
office and so Bush read this and he
became a painter and he became actually
a pretty good painter even the left-wing
New York magazine said he did a good job
and he would paint portraits of wounded
warriors and the soldiers and he would
sell these as fundraisers who would give
them to people he published a book of
his art it's really about other people
and it's about whether or not you like
his order or not it's about bringing
together different artistic styles into
a beautiful composition to do honor to
great warriors that's real art for the
left however they don't have any sense
of real art because they don't have any
sense of beauty so it's all
deconstruction it's all Dada it's all
absurdism it's all ugly it's all bizarre
it's all surreal it's all this kind of
performance art you know the the right
loves good art and the left loves
terrible art like this sort of
performance art er slam poetry which the
literary critic Harold Bloom rightly
called the death of art and this really
highlights it in these two prominent
politicians you've got the one going
toward the beautiful and the one going
toward the grotesque and the absurd and
the obscene and that's Hillary Clinton
no better way to describe her and I'm
not at all surprised that the artistic a
preferences of she and her comrades
reflect their own bizarre views of the
world that's our show we got more to get
to we'll do it on Monday in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Nolt show have a good weekend see you
soon
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina
hair and makeup is by joshua alvera and
our production assistant is nick Chien
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show the democratic
debate gave us a picture of a country
where everything is free except for you
we'll talk about it on the Andrew Klavan
show on Andrew Clayton
[Music]